and tom brady we know now we don't know
that he will be playing for the
buccaneers in 2022 but he is under
contract now
through 2022 and only tom brady can pull
off this feat where
while taking less he ends up getting
more he does that all the time i took
less i took less what'd you get i got
more he was supposed to get 25 million
this year he's getting 41 million at
least earning 41 million this year what
they did he was supposed to make 25
million this year second year of a
two-year 50 million dollar deal he has a
new two-year 50 million dollar deal the
way it's broken down
he earns 41 million this year but he
gets 15 million of that next year so
he's really not getting much more this
year they got the avoidable years on the
back end the new device for teams to
take cap space and shove it into future
years he created 19.3 million in cap
space for the bucks end of the day he's
basically got the same deal and and
there's a neat little twist what the
bucks did here if he would retire after
this year they don't have to go chase
him for unearned bonus money they just
don't pay him the 15 million they got
pushed into next year as part of the
signing bonus so if he stays he gets 50
million over the next two years and
there's no reason to think he won't say
people were amazed that tom brady did a
deal that puts him out of contract
through the year that he turns 45.
he's been saying for almost 45 years
he's going to play until he's 45. right
so why are we surprised by that i'm not
surprised no definitely not and
especially with the way that team's
fixed and you know ready to go right now
i mean one of the better o-lines in
football the weapons everything like
that i mean i i don't again two years
i'm not putting it out of the realm of
possibility certainly not i mean i think
we're still going to see a really good
tom brady this year and this just leaves
the door open i mean
again i don't know what what does this
mean does this mean they're going to be
able to get shaq barrett mike do you
think this this this move was all about
that or is it other things on the roster
they're trying to get accomplished i i
doubt that you were reading any pft over
the week not all the time usually i'm
over it yeah i had an item yesterday
that listed all the pass rushes
something you and i have discussed
discussed i decided to actually you know
roll up the sleeves and do some work
looked up all the pass rushers are going
to be available and von miller may still
be available by the time it's all said
and done there's so many pass rushers
out there i think the buccaneers instead
of paying huge money to shaq barrett
they're going to look for another shaq
barrett they paid him one year four
million
in 2019 he was coming off of five years
with the broncos where he had 14 total
sacks in those five years combined and
he had 19 and a half sacks in todd
bowles system for what you're going to
pay shaq barrett to keep him
why not sign two pass rushers and
somebody else
so i i just think
it gets back to dollar for dollar value
that's going to be such a key message
this year
what do you think you're getting for the
investment i think for what it's going
to take to sign shaq barrett when you
consider there's going to be some other
team out there that's going to want to
hold up the jersey and say we got the
top defensive player from the buccaneers
championship run of 2020
fine great enjoy your payday we're going
to spend that money elsewhere on some of
these other great pass rushers who are
going to be much much much cheaper than
shaq barrett i think that's what they're
going to yeah i i that could make that
makes sense it does it really does i
think when you think of the grand scheme
of of their football team and where it
goes too you know because you you
mentioned the players they got there all
right there's still a lot of good on
that d line even without shaq barrett
and i think we both have mentioned this
you know number of times when you got
vita veya
who is going to be up for contract in a
few years and when he i mean again as
we've talked about a lot when he's
healthy he's one of the more disruptive
defensive tackles in football then devin
white coming up here in the next two
years year and a half after this season
right after this season he's eligible
that's where i got i got to think
they're looking at going what how much
money can we possibly put into the front
seven here in the future and maybe this
is one they take your approach mike get
one of those guys maybe a one or two
year deal and a weird
you might get who knows you could get a
leonard floyd in a year like this for
like a you know two-year deal that
averages 14 or 15 million a year and go
well we'll take that rather than you
know shaq barrett at 20 million a year
right now and having to pay out all that
big money too
or you just do what the patriots are
going to do you wait and you wait and
you wait and you're waiting and then
they're calling no bargain shop saying
you know what i'm not getting i'm not
getting the deal that i wanted so i'm
going to come join forces with tom brady
i mean this is the year to do it for
pass rushers we know how important they
are look at the item at pft go to the
search function pass rushers it'll take
you to the story put in shaq barrett's
name it was yesterday morning there
there are a ton there are 14
pass rushers in the pft top 100 free
agency list and none of them were
franchise tagged so they're out there
and i think that's what the buccaneers
are going to do and speaking of vida
veya he's currently eligible for a new
contract we don't know how aggressively
he's clamoring for a new deal he had
that injury last year that caused him to
miss a lot of the season guys want their
security guys want their value guys want
to shift the injury risk from them to
the team he could be saying i want mine
now we know devon white's gonna want his
and deserve his after this season so i
think we're onto something here i think
the bucks realize that one of the
casualties of winning the super bowl is
that they didn't want to pay 18.99
million to tag shaq barrett again and
have him for one more year let's just
redirect that money elsewhere
and let's try to find another shaq
barrett we found him two years ago let's
try to find another one you're right a
lot of avenues and you you mentioned
some of the names you know olivier
vernon's they'd be a guy you'd look at
and go he's not going to get huge money
but still got some you know gas in the
tank that makes sense you know melvin
ingram let's not forget about him with
the chargers he's going to fit that mold
of where it's like you know a two-year
deal probably a decent amount of money
in year one and we'll see if he can earn
year two and those type of things so
mike i did see your article yesterday
just so you know uh and yeah i think
that is a very real aspect and you're
right the bucks are one of those teams
that makes a lot of sense and and again
they have an elite unit really there
already and you just can't make one unit
so strong and have so much resources as
far as money that it ruins your rest of
your team for the future too so uh i
think that's i think we are on to
something mike i'm with just consider
this consider this and i'm going to go
ahead and do this now i pulled up the
article and i'm not going to read as
fast as the guy in the old fedex
commercials who would just like rattle
things off but but just if you're
interested in what's going to be out
there bucks fans matthew jude on carl
lawson hassan reddick trey hendrickson
leonard floyd bud dupree yannick and
gawkway romeo akwara carlos dunlap
justin houston olivier vernon ryan
carrick and denicko autry alden smith
jadavian clowney melvin ingram john
simon everson griffin marcus gold and
bruce irvin all unrestricted free agents
yeah all of them right yeah that's a a
hell of a list and you're right you
would think you're gonna find somebody
from there that's gonna get a pretty
good bargain
not have to send you know spend 20
million dollars a year and still get
good production so they're sitting
pretty the bucks and good for brady gets
a little more money right now whatever
uh but the bucks are are looking like a
team to be reckoned with once again in
2021
and you know look he could have taken
actually less but there's a point where
hey he's the reason you told the story
about your dad dean being down in tampa
for the super bowl and you can't find a
jersey other than tom brady because
that's the only one people want to buy
right they're going to fill that stadium
this year they're going to fill that
stadium next year every week i mean he
reached four years ago when they beat
the falcons in super bowl 50
one yeah that was the one 51 yeah um and
and uh that that's when he reached that
michael jordan you must be able to tell
your grandchildren you saw this guy play
level that's where he is and it's even
stronger now with seven super bowl wins
as he goes for number eight they're
going to make a ton of money off of this
guy and even 25 million when you look at
the greater scheme of the quarterback
it's it's nothing dollar for dollar we
talk about dollar dollar value tom brady
at 25 million or 26 or whatever they
ended up making the final number that's
a pretty damn good value when you
consider the top of the markets 45
dak prescott's getting 40. russell
wilson's at 35. 25 is a pretty damn good
deal for a guy who came in and
transformed the culture of a franchise
that's right success of a franchise in
one year yeah no that you that's that's
the value to me i mean yeah he's not one
of the five best quarterbacks in
football at this point of his career but
he's still damn good
and he brought that aspect that value to
the team you know you can't quantify
that part of it you know he brought the
polish the confidence you know the
grittiness to the football team to
believe that we can win these tough
football games all of that stuff that's
what they were missing and that's where
brady really was unbelievable and yeah
mike i mean it's legendary status it's a
whole different stratosphere of what he
is in our country now with seven super
bowls being tom brady everything like
that uh i i'm glad he didn't take less
like we talked about he's actually he's
too big now to be taking you know one
million dollars a year or anything like
that there's too much value to tom brady
and that name behind it
that said and this is a little nod for
our friends in the uk and ireland soccer
star the other football star david
beckham on the beach with tom brady
looking like a member of the green bay
packers defense intercepting tom brady
here's the video brady it was a bad
route and then the guy just stood there
you're asking for an interception i know
it's always the quarterback's fault but
he kept telling the guy go deep go deep
and the guy didn't believe him and and
he just kind of and he just kind of
stood there now oh there's another pick
yeah but the first one the first one's
the best one too because oh i wish if we
could go back to the first one yeah
you're right because when i think
beckham intercepts it first off too he
runs the wrong direction that's where i
was like this guy
he's obvious look at him he's going off
the side dude the end zone is the other
eye what are you doing marshall
marshall
but that's really cool to see those two
together and that warm weather looks
really nice too brady you could tell his
knee is not totally
like normal though like as you watch
those videos you can see he's a little
ginger with that left knee still so
probably rehabbing that thing right now
he's had surgery yeah he's announced
that he's he's got the wrap on it at all
times bruce aryans the head coach of the
team has said he'll be good to go for
seven on sevens in june so it's gotta be
hard for him to be out of that routine
and not be able to go as hard as he
otherwise would i'm sure he's still
finding ways to keep himself in shape
definitely but a different kind of thing
for him and that left knee that was the
one that was collapsed by bernard
pollard week one 2008 and had the torn
acl and other damage and he had an
infection and it was a lifetime ago yeah
that was i mean i'm telling you this
guy's working on his third super bowl
bust he's got the pre-2008 bust he's got
the 2014 through 2018
bust and now he's working on bus number
three with the tampa bay buccaneers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports